I've had problems with gins. I had to
get one removed by um really Yeah. It it
was I felt it was like a dark just and I
looked up. Have you do you play surah
bakar in your house? What's the second
chapter of Quran? Look when I sung that
awah bak. Ah,
how do you feel?
Feel rest.
Just imagine the people back in the day
when they would have to travel certain
distances for months or even years. What
is one thing that they would carry with
them? The Quran. Why? Because they did
not have it on their mobile devices or
their gadgets. Brothers and sisters,
imagine you have a app, the Qurani app,
which not only shows you how much
rewards you get, but reminds you to read
the Quran, gives you reminders. Download
the Qurani app now and let it testify
for you on your Makyama that you read it
wherever you was. Where's the military
one?
Where's the military one? The military
one.
What's going on here? Sorry, I'm a
Muslim. Salamkum Kabir Rah. How you
doing? What happened to you? Why was you
doing that for? I It's just a song. I
mean, the thing is, right? Um there's
I've got these uh I can't do it. It's
It's What was it doing? You can do it
again. What was it?
[Music]
What is that? It's a It's a song that
I've got at home and it's like house but
with that flavor. Are you sure there's
no gins in this music? Gins. Gins. Gins.
There may well be gins in the music. I
was going to say, yeah, but um the thing
about gins is you know these the thing
about the malevolent gin, right?
Malevolent. What do you mean by that?
Was it what I mean is troublesome,
causing problems. Uh distracting from
the truth. Yes. Uh trying to draw you
away from your faith. Does that make
sense? How long you been a Muslim?
2008 I took shahadi at the 2008. Yeah,
it was it was during Ramadan. Okay. And
it was the right the the imam at this
place. He drew me in with his amazing uh
charisma. Well, actually it was
something he did with his voice. He made
this funny sound and I felt this sense
of peace around him. Okay. And the thing
is right this the mosque is um in
Whitman Road near Tempite Lane. Oh yeah,
I know that one. You know that one?
Yeah, that's where and I I had a direct
blessing from Allah,
right? And it was saying come and join
us we I love
you. We can he felt my genuine interest
and I I str I was not there's not many
you So you've been a Muslim for 17
years. Okay. So I'm assuming you know
how to pray? Yes. Okay. So um Okay. You
pray five times a day. I praying not
just I am praying now. Okay. No I mean I
mean I ask you salah. Do you pray five
times a day? Well look I don't follow
the that aspect but I do follow the the
the core teaching of the Quran. Okay. So
you believe God is one. Yes. Sorry. I
know I know it's I feel the oneness.
Okay. And I feel the oneness with all my
compatriots, whether they be Muslim,
Buddhist, Christian, or or non-believer.
I feel the oneness. You know, I'm not
joking. I'm not just saying that. And
it's so powerful. And it keeps me going
in times of trouble. I've had 5 years of
hell, but I just come out of it. And
when you come out of a lot of suffering,
problems, financial, relationship, all
it's a it's and what made me do it was
my Muslim faith because
I've tried many religions, Christian,
Buddhist. Yeah. But there's something
magical about Islam. You know what it
is, right?
It's the you know when when Muhammad,
peace be upon his soul, Yeah.
first was recognized as a very important
man and a prophet. Yeah, it were the
Sufis, the Sufis, the Nakbandies,
the the um my master is from my my Sufi
master, right? He's a Sufi. Oh, you're a
Sufi. Well, I started as Sufi, but okay.
I people said to me, look, if you're
Sufi, you you must be a Muslim. You you
can't be a Sufi and not a Muslim. So I
thought Yeah. Yeah. And and I I resisted
at first, but yeah. My it was 1991 when
I had a direct mind to mind from my Sufi
master. What does that mean? Um it's a a
telepathic communication. Okay.
Telepath. And it kind of was saying come
come in and find out the secrets of your
existence. And also
you will be it's telling me you will be
of benefit to many people because you
will unite the separate faction and I've
I feel that I mean but how do you how do
you know it was not a gin that's
speaking to you because it I' I've had
problems with gins I had to get one
removed by um really yeah it it was I
felt it was like a dark just and I
looked up and it moves back and it is it
had attached itself and I and have you
read the do you play surah Bakar in your
house? What's Surah Bakar? Surah Bakar
the second chapter of Quran. You should
play in your house. So dispel all this
kind of stuff. So pray surah Bakar. Well
look this is Have you heard it before?
Can I play it for you? Yeah. Go on then.
Yeah. Listen. Look. Let me show you.
What's your name by the way? Ali. Ali.
Nice meeting you. Yeah.
Look when I sung that you
know. Ah.
You're trying to face this way. I'll
hold it. That's beautiful. Yeah. I'll
hold it. I'll hold it. Let me know how
you feel.
So guys, I'm just playing the surah to
the brother. He said he has some gym
problems. See if he's heard of it
before. It's very powerful to stay in
your house. Okay. Tell this stuff.
How do you feel?
Feel rested. I feel at peace and I feel
that even if a jin comes, I can Yeah.
Exactly. Exactly. This one of the most
power in there. This is incred. This is
what the Imam did to me when he first
saw me. He was doing that and I felt
this wave of peace and love and
protection. Should I stop it or do you
want to carry for a little bit more? I
could listen to that all night. Yeah.
Okay. It's called Surah Bakar. Go on
YouTube and write Surah Bakar. Surah
Bakar Bak. Can you write that down?
Yeah.
Sheh, he he had some he had some gin
issues. I just made Surah Bakar. He
found it really tranquil and he said I
can fight off all the gins with this.
Can you write bakar uh down? He wants to
go home and listen to it inah. So subh.
This is actually very
powerful. All right. Okay. Sorry. Can I
may I ask what's these?
Sorry. The guided prayer. Oh yeah. They
teach you how to pray salah. If you
don't know how to pray salah. Do you
know how to pray?
I'm still learning. You don't? Okay.
This for you. Let me give you one. Yeah.
So this has a guided wood. Uh it teach
how to do woodoo and you can learn how
to pray salah. It has a it tells you how
to pray salah step by step. It's for
free. Exactly. Thank you. Yeah, man. And
if you want to learn, if you want to
book an instructor, go to the back uh on
the QR code here. It's scan here and uh
you can go to our website and you can
find us on the app store. Yeah. Yeah.
And you can book an instructor. Somebody
will come out and teach you how to pray.
Thank you. No problem. What's your name?
Reuben. Reuben. That's when I'm live on
my YouTube channel. You can say hi.
Guys, it's Reuben. He's How long you
been Muslim? Um maybe a couple months
now. Wow. A couple of months. Okay.
Yeah. Yeah. If you want, I can even come
out and teach you how to pray Salah.
This is teaches you how to pray. Are you
Muslim? Yeah. You know how to pray? Uh
learn. You're learning. Should I give
you that as well? Yeah. This will teach
you how to pray salah. How long you been
a Muslim?
Okay. Okay. No problem. This will help
you, bro. This for this not just for
rebirth. It's for even those who don't
know how to pray salah in. So, we just
want people to learn how to pray salah.
This will teach you teach you how to do
wudoo. Yeah. It's for
uh salah plus.com. There's a QR code at
the back. Scan it and you can book a
salah instructor and if you want to
learn, somebody will come and teach you.
Thank you. Take care. Everybody look
after yourself. Take care.
I am a rever and I was taught how to
pray salah. That means every single time
I pray the person who told me gets the
reward five times a day from fud to is
if you want to support someone like me
in learning salah then sponsor 10 people
for just $100 this Ramadan. Remember the
prophet peace be upon him said charity
does not decrease wealth. Click the
button and donate now.